[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
à m sila mon amour est ce que l'artiste
il est parti ouais l'artiste et parce
que tu es dans le tibet mes enfants et
je leur les doigts mais j'en ai marre
quoi depuis juillet on m'appelle
chocolat chaud peu je suis pas jazzy
mire
géraldine géraldine série l'1 vous est
offert un livre n'est le prendre voilà
c'est celui ci ouvre des voies la fuite
et oui nous aimait bien vous lisez des
trucs non je n'ai pas lu n'a rien dedans
n'y a rien c'est une autobiographie de
la carrière de leurs maux
[Applaudissements]
je commence doucement tu vois ça l'a
tous reconnu avec ses longs cheveux
bouclés
non
des chars les gibson
c'est vrai mais un truc à dire ayoub
d'hannibal pour la suite de sa carrière
reculer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
quatre aux jo qui tu es tu ne le vois
pas je me sacrifierai pas indemme jules
verne est question de la bagarre oui
merci
[Applaudissements]
mathieu je crois qu'ils qui vous séduit
au top comme ça tu sais pas il me dit
écoute à l'occasion c'est un peu dans le
cinéma tu feras des seconds rôles je
peux faire des premiers héros non j'ai
pas dit non mais a circulé pas mal dans
le cinéma
vous êtes le commencer un petit peu
c'est que je peux jouer à la lumière oui
vous avez déjà pris vont un très très
gros râteau à m sila
si la vérité moi ouais ouais ouais ouais
c'était quoi jour le râteau non mais en
fait moi j'étais ctcc ça c'était le
meilleur ami moi j'étais toujours le
meilleur pote
ah ouais ouais moi j'ai ramené les
gouttes et les goûter mais j'avais
jamais le droit de goûter mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]